it has often been said that the most
important man on the movie set is the
cameraman it has been said most often by
the cameraman
I'm certainly not going to argue because
I need all the help I can get to present
the cinematography Awards here are two
handsome people who don't need help any
help
Miss Jean Simmons and mr. Rock Hudson
ain't that's your close-up camera over
there
and that one's mine uh Bob where's my
camera kid you're not gonna get anywhere
in this business by being pushy
will you start the list please date
nominees for the best achievement in
cinematography of a black-and-white
picture
Philip H Lathrop for the Americanization
of Emily Naughton Krasner for faders 100
go give Bayat form which has sweet
Charlotte Gabriel Figaro for the night
of the iguana Walter luckily for Joe by
the Greek and the winner is the winner
is
Walter Natalie for Zorba the geek
ding ball Walter la Sally arlene dahl
oh he's so beautiful easy dude well I
just want to thank you it somebody
dropped something
I just want to thank all of you the
Board of Directors and the Academy for
making this possible for mr. La Salette
I know how thrilled we must be his
beautiful camerawork contributed greatly
to the previous absorber the Greek thank
you so much for him
nominees for the best achievement in
cinematography of a color picture are
the Jeffrey Unsworth for Beckett William
H clover for Cheyenne autumn Edward
Coleman for Mary Poppins Perry
struggling for my fair lady Daniel L
fell for the Unsinkable Molly Brown and
the winner is Harry Stradlin for my fair
lady
I'd like to thank Jack Warner George
Cukor for giving me the opportunity to
photograph his family a special thanks
to miss all the headline that her
appreciation and many many thanks to my
crew thank you